authors meetings for the textbook you
were reading and we came to talk about
Rome with one of our author team Steve
Hirsch being a specialist on the ancient
world the idea of comparing Rome with
Han China seems like just about as good
an idea as
peanut-butter-and-jelly I mean at this
it just really fit and it seems probably
pelling up less of a debate over this
chapter them than any other and I think
that's probably a mistake like many
ideas that are you know really really
good on first inspection they don't
necessarily hold up but it does raise
the questions to apply the similarities
as you think about the more not seem to
be as salient as they first appeared and
what would have been a better comparison
if you had determined that at some point
rather than having a sort of a tea party
of different cultures which we had in
our earlier chapters you wanted to have
a direct comparison from three from two
dramatically different cultural zones I
think I would probably now argue that a
comparison between Greece in the period
before Alexander the Great and the Joe
dynasty
in in China that is save the dynasty
before the Han which was chaotic and
divided him to a lot of competing
principalities rather analogous in some
way to the competing city-states of
Greece but also which gave rise to the
culture that that idolized Confucius who
lived after all in the supposedly born
around 551 BCE he's way before the Han
Dynasty and therefore he is in the same
timeframe as as the pre-socratic
philosophers and then moving on with his
disciples to the later Greek
philosophers in some ways that now seems
to me perhaps to have been a better
comparison and then let Iran and India
be together without having those Greeks
interloping on their Aryan purity but
then you'd have a question of what do
you do with Rome and of course I've
already raised the question in this
class of how do you escape the Bible a
Bible in which there is comparatively
little that is historically provable
that covers a comparatively small area
that isn't a terribly long text but that
nevertheless has been the source of
endless images moral examples historical
lessons and so forth for
no the last two and a half thousand
years Rome has something of that same
quality that is to say the temptation to
look at Rome as a model of what happens
in a in a country that engages in
imperial expansion seems to be you know
irresistible whether it is Napoleon
styling his empire on Rome's
or whether it is one of the casandra's
that we have around us in the in this
country saying that we're going to go
the way of Rome and fall or whether you
have a classic work that nobody reads
the decline and fall of the Roman Empire
in which you think decline and fall what
a cool concept and you actually think
it's about Rome all the way through
whereas actually it starts rather late
in the game Rome is just always always
there so so you have to somehow carve
out a special place for the Roman
experience the question is whether that
place is within Europe and the
Mediterranean and the Hellenistic world
because you could easily imagine writing
a history of the Hellenistic world in
which you would have a chapter that
would combine the Greek kingdoms that
followed Alexander the Kingdom of the
Ptolemies in Egypt or the kingdom of the
Seleucids in Syria and Iraq and for a
while in Iran and the Kingdom of Romans
which began of course as a kingdom
became a republic and then became a
vampire but in any case it was clearly
Hellenistic there's though as no
doubting that the Romans slavishly
copied Greek art they performed Greek
plays they admired and extended the
teachings of Greek philosophers and they
enslaved every Greek that you get their
hands on not quite but they had no
particular respect for Greeks but for
everything the Greeks had wrought they
had great respect and one of the
products of that of course is the fact
that romanization is not comparable to
hellenization the territories that were
romanized were primarily parts of Europe
that had never been influenced by the by
the practices of of the Greek world and
had never been conquered by Alexander
the Great so that for northern europe
north western europe and south western
europe rome is truly the model and you
get romanization but wherever the romans
went as successors to the greeks
as successors to the successors to
alexander their language did not take
root and the culture that comes to be
honored is not a Roman culture but
rather the culture of the hellings who
are being superseded politically but not
culturally or ideologically so
you could probably say what we need here
is a chapter on the on hellenization of
the late ancient world that would take
up the Ptolemies and the Salukis and the
romans in a single chapter in another
chapter comparing the world of the Greek
city-states
with the chaotic so-called feudal
disputes that you had in Crete on China
but that wasn't the way it seemed when
we were setting up the table of contents
instead it seemed like Han China and
Rome fit well together and why was that
the case what what made them seem like
well does they happen at the same time
and it's amazing what synchrony will do
to to historians they will say oh this
happened here and this is happier just
at the same time Wow look at that
and then they'll know my favorite
comparison is mohammad ahmad abu lahab
in arabia is born in the same year as
John Wesley in London and I say gee that
must be sign of some sort and so I write
you know an elaborate essay based on
that on trying to make sense out of that
particular total coincidence because
synchrony is is a is a drug for
historians and they do get invest in
things that happened the same time so
the Roman Empire you know you go from
the Punic Wars where the Romans are
really establishing their their hold
outside of Italy by fighting against the
against the Carthaginians and that's
right at the time of the beginning of
the Han Dynasty in China when after the
very brief tyrannical period of the Qin
you have
this new long live dynasty that lasts
until you know 221 c e 221 a little
early for the end of the Roman Empire on
the other hand if you just go 80 years
later you get the Emperor Diocletian who
splits the Empire between east and west
and once it split I mean who cares if
later Roman history just doesn't have
the the riveting quality as the story of
the Republic and the and the transition
to the empire by the time you get past
300 or even past 250 you're mired down
in barbarian invasions and efforts by a
dizzying sequence of of emperors to try
and find some way to to retain or
hopefully we establish some Authority
for the Empire so if you go from 200 BC
to 280 200 BCE to 200 C II you have a
han dynasty and if you take those same
dates and you put them in Roman context
you're going from the Punic Wars down to
the you know increasing impact of the
Germanic invaders and so you've seem to
have a nice synchrony then you know the
synchrony of the fact that there are
barbarians and say well that's that's
cool because you have two empires each
empires be set by barbarians and you
read Chinese history and you find that
the Chinese term different peoples
Western barbarians or northern
barbarians or southern barbarians or
Eastern barbarians
and then particularly with the eastern
barbarians like Korea and Japan they
eventually decide they're not our
barians once they adopt Chinese customs
but if you actually look at it in
Chinese you'll find that isn't the same
word modified by directions those are
different those are different terms it's
the word barbarian that English
translators have used to draw those
words together you could use the word
foreigner just as well but barbarian is
what gets used and the reason for this
is primarily because the people whom the
Chinese encountered on the north were
pastoral nomads in inner Asia but let me
say that I'll probably use the term
Central Asia for the western portion of
the Eurasian steppe what today would be
um was Beck Astana Kazakhstan
Turkmenistan Tajikistan and inner Asia
for areas still further to the east
Mongolia and Chinese provinces of
shinjang and gone to in the northwest of
contemporary China but the Chinese were
facing a pastoral nomadic adversaries in
in their north-west most notably shownu
and the Romans were facing adversaries
in their northeast tour who were if not
pastoral nomads at least they were
nomads not as dependent upon horse
culture as as the later nomads that come
in from the east
the Germans are who are the primary
migrating folk of the Roman period don't
fall into that category of steppe nomads
exactly but people will say well both
empires were facing these nomadic
pressures and both empires built
elaborate fortifications - to protect
their empire in the case of the Chinese
it's the great wall which actually comes
into being in stages but it certainly
was intended as a barrier against nomads
from the north in the in Rome who had
the wordly mace which was used for a
fortified frontier as it turns out most
of the of the fortifications were not
against the nomads in the north but
rather against nomads in Algeria and in
Tunisia
nevertheless the whole idea of trying to
to wall out your enemy was shared
between the two states and then you look
at the map you say well here we have the
Eurasian landmass and that the western
end of it we have a Roman Empire the
eastern end of it we have a Chinese
Empire or if you're looking at it from
your point of view at the western end of
it you have the Romans the East
you have a Chinese and so then you can
talk about the middle and what what is
there is there something about their
common foe
that is defining and of course it became
helpful when a French geologist said
that chungmu was probably the origin of
the word hun because the Huns attack the
Romans only four hundred years after the
shenmue attacked the Chinese and what's
four hundred years when you're dealing
with Asian history
nobody really accepts the show-nu hun
comparison today so far as I can tell at
least they don't say that they're the
same people and in fact it's not exactly
clear who the Huns were in any sort of
ethnic or linguistic terms so that for
the Huns who become an important part of
Europe for a brief time in the fifth
century you have a you have several
personal names and three actual words
that are known on the basis of that
certain philologist have said well they
must somehow be related to the Turks
there's primarily well if not primarily
at least eminent among them was Omega
O'Malley I'm Chris Sacca
a specialist on Ukrainian history who
said well their language wasn't like the
Turkic languages it was more like
chuvash and the thing is with Chris Sauk
whom I knew here his test for anyone who
knew languages us to you know to wash
and because to Bosch which is an obscure
language spoken in in Russia
sort of the the model of obscure
languages and quit sock would always
hold it over you whether or not you knew
Subash I have no idea whether Hunnic was
related to Chu Bosch or not but I would
never I would never doubt it
I just wouldn't bet the house on it so
you have a seemingly comparison of two
empires against possibly a similar
economic formation represented by inter
Asian and Central Asian
nomads whom you call barbarians I should
point out as I mentioned before that a
barbarian is not originally a Latin term
it's a Greek term that refers to people
who do not speak speak Greek there are
other languages in the world that have
terms for sort of the unspeakable other
in in Arabic use word Adam
sorry listen a on there which literally
means people who don't speak Arabic and
the ad junkies man your's or they could
be Persians it's the same as with barbed
arrows in in Greek in ancient India
you use the word Malecha Malecha those
were the people who weren't Indians so
that if you find yourself at a cocktail
party and people are talking about
Sanskrit words for the other you'll know
what that one is
but the point is that the idea of having
a categorical term before the other was
not peculiar to the Romans and the
notion of a barbarian was a fairly
flexible one somewhat complex in its in
the evolution of flexibility for example
the word only occurs in once in the
Iliad or in all of Homer and it occurs
in the form of barbaric windows which
means having a language that sounds like
bar barbar and that apparently it was
used to refer to allies of the Trojans
who spoke who are the Carians who spoke
a language descended from lthien and
old language of Anatolia that the Greeks
absolutely could not understand and so
Homer said this is Bob Bravo no it
sounds like barbar but if at the time of
Homer you know talking about 89 BC the
idea that all non Greeks are barbarians
wasn't there by the time you got to
Aristotle the notion that non Greeks are
barbarians and as such are natural
slaves has come to be a fleeting Greek
obsession which is pretty much gone by
the time the Romans take over in Greece
and the Greeks themselves
many instances become slaves so the
Romans simply inherit this usage the say
that the reduplicated syllable barbar
it's always said that that means because
it sounds like a non Greek language
actually I think it is more correct to
say it sounds like an animal sound I
once made a very large collection of the
sounds that animals make in different
languages in the world who say well you
know if we say a dog goes our ARF what
does an Arab say a dog goes have hat
what does a Korean say the dog goes long
long and through two different species
of animals you have this variation
around the world that's quite
substantial I had in mind to write a
children's book on the whole thing but I
figured that teaching five-year-olds how
Koreans say arf arf probably wasn't
going to sell but but the interesting
thing was that the the we duplication of
syllables
was the common the common practice that
when you have reduplicated syllables the
suggestion is that it's it's not human
speech and these animal sounds are
actually quite interesting because
they're you can't usually conjugate them
in other words a dog does not arf-arf
and say oh he are parked at me or he
arced at me even but rather he barked so
you have another tier of words that
signify animals making sounds that our
animal sounds but they're not the actual
sounds that you say if we're trying to
imitate those animal sounds within the
phonemic range of your particular
language and they're certainly not the
animal sounds that you make if you are
trying to imitate the animal and here of
course it's interesting that if a Korean
or an Arab or an American tries to
imitate let's say a dog barking they
will make the same shout something like
that but if they're trying to
characterize it then it has to be
subjected to the phonemic phonemic array
of possibilities within their particular
languages this wasn't on my program for
today to talk about this but it's very
interesting really I think it has a lot
to do with the origins of human of human
speech I think before you I think these
animal sounds are pre syntactic that you
know you're out there and you want to
say what was on the other side of the
hill and you didn't yet know how to say
you know there is a lion on the other
side of the hill and you roaring like a
lion was one thing to do but then could
also say roar roar or something like
that anyhow the Ewell synchrony you have
the appearance of empire
you have the apparent geographical
location at opposite ends of a great
continuous stretch of territory from
Eastern Europe across to northern China
and these seem to warrant a comparison
but then you say it's an empire well in
what sense it's an empire the Romans
conquered everybody
and so if you say an empire is a
powerful political state that subjects
other people's originally independent to
their domination and does so in the you
know through military or later economic
means well then
Rome is sort of your paradigmatic Empire
the Romans always denied it their idea
was that they never fought an offensive
war they defended their borders all the
way to Iran and that was important to
them because there was a if you go back
to the stories that Libby tells us about
the Roman Kingdom you find that there
was a class of priests called the fakie
Ollie's and when you had a dispute with
the neighbor you know your nail you know
the people in the neighboring from the
neighboring town Sol you know stole
Publius as goat the petty allies would
go to the to the border with that
city-state or whatever and they would
yell across the border you all better
returned Publius is goat are you're
going to be in big trouble and and then
they wait and if Publius tinkin is goat
back they would go back and report that
there had been a failure to to
compensate to make amends for the
aggression of the other side and that
therefore
the god of the gods would support a war
and it was important for the Romans that
the gods were always on their side and
this is the way they guarantee their
eyes on their side was by construing
every campaign they had as an act of
Defense and then if by good luck they
happen to concur and then they'd
establish their border at some further
point and then defend that border until
they could span beyond it
so the Romans were expensive and they
were they were bureaucratized in a
fashion that enabled them to accommodate
different different territories with
different status levels as they as they
expanded so that what initially would be
sort of recently conquered territory
would down the road become you know
closely allied and then become part of
an expanded notion of Rome itself until
eventually well into the period of the
empire all the people ruled by the
Romans were declared to be citizens of
Rome so they were organized for for
conquest
both in the military sense they were
very effective and in the sense that
they had bureaucratic and political
instruments for for administering and
eventually assimilating territories they
conquered but China was not an empire in
that sense the Han Dynasty did take over
northern China
which had been unified by the short live
chim who preceded them but they did not
then perform prodigies of conquest they
remained pretty much where they were for
their four centuries of existence and
this was not a completely homogeneous
territory there we were various peoples
whom they regarded as as non Chinese and
we know very little about these these
people we have their names and sometimes
terms suggesting how this people was
related to this other people but
basically we know very little about the
neighbors of the Chinese other than the
Machine knew that had an actual
effective Kingdom to the north of China
up in the inner Asia but the Han for
example did not expand into southern
China the division between northern
China and southern China is the answer
River
it is a significant division not simply
because it is a major river but because
the the military realities on the north
side are very different from the
military realities on the south side of
the north side you have various rivers
but basically northern China is a is a
plain often called the North China Plain
very ingeniously and it was very good
for her horse warfare
so the hon developed chariotry they
developed cavalry they borrow the the
practices of the inner Asian nomads and
that pattern of borrowing from
interation nomads continues for
centuries after the demise of the Han so
there's a very important linkage
northward of a technological and
military sort but the area south of the
Yangtze River first area while in the
river is not as marshy and not suitable
for horse activities and the area
further south is much chillier than in
the north and basically the han armies
were not were not equipped to invade the
south in the way that the Romans were
invaded everybody they knew and in fact
the peoples in the south were able to
use the river boundary as a protection
and ultimately when you finally do have
the North the northern Chinese states
going to the south
a lot of it has to do with the
development of naval forces on the Aqsa
River because it is in such a formidable
geographical barrier so China is not
under the Han is not a great military
expansive power that Rome is and does
not develop the same degree of
bureaucratize ation about the Romans
have when you look back at the history
of Chinese law and bureaucracy or
Chinese law and administration you don't
particularly look to the Han although
there are certain Confucian inspired
advisors who who are very important as
counselors to the Han rulers but
it is really for the Tong dynasty that
comes into being around 600 AD or 600 CE
II that that becomes the model so
whereas in European history Roman law
becomes a model that existed in the
robot or came into being in Roman times
and ultimately is revived and made into
an important foundation for modern
European law in China the parallel of
Roman law would be the great tong law
code which has nothing new Han it comes
hundreds of years later although
starting around 600 it is it falls into
the same period of the revival of Roman
law so so Han doesn't have the that kind
of a parallel it doesn't lay down a
system for example later on in China you
have an examination system by which
people who work for the government must
pass a series of examinations this is
not a Hogg practice this is later later
Chinese history so Han doesn't have that
kind of paradigmatic place that Rome has
for history in the West then there's
another sort of interesting non
comparison and it is one that has
to some degree become put in the past by
recent scholarship of what originally
amounted to was the argument that Rome
was an economy built on slavery and that
is going back to my what I've talked
about in earlier lecture about energy
profiles that human muscle power was the
primary source of energy in Roman times
slaves were not only abundant because of
Wars but they were discardable more or
less in Roman law you did not have to
treat slaves in a humane inhumane
fashion
China really didn't have slavery at the
I don't mean they didn't have slavery
there were slaves but they're just as
likely to be poor people who were sort
of the came attached to a household as
as semi members of the household as they
were anything else you didn't have any
notion for example that barbarians were
natural slaves there was no category of
natural slaves in the home period since
the Han were not conquering and
producing huge numbers of of prisoners
of war you didn't have a massive supply
of human labour
and yet China appears to have been quite
well populated there doesn't appear to
have been a labor shortage and one of
the questions in Roman history has
always been what was the character of
the labor supply in the ancient world
was how would you get along without
slavery and eventually the population
that is seems to be robust in the early
Roman Empire the population begins to
shrink and the successor states to Rome
seem to be of a much more modest
population size and that is true China
as well there is a census from the Han
period that suggests that China under
the Han had maybe 50 million people and
several hundred years later there's
another census that is less complete
doesn't cover the entire territory but
it comes in at about 16 million people
which has led historians to think that
the the chaotic conditions that followed
the fall of the Han in the 3rd century
CE II led to a great shrinkage of the
population in the same way that the
chaotic conditions of the late Roman
Empire and then of the post Roman
situation in Europe led to a shrinkage
of population there but in the European
case the shrinkage population is seen to
have significant economic implications
this was a thesis put forward first I
think by a French
historian named Rashard Lefevre they
know at and his thesis was that in Rome
all significant work was done by slaves
after Rome fell there was a shortage of
labour and this led people to invent new
ways to use animals and particularly it
led the French to invent new ways to use
animals to harness them more efficiently
and according to Lefebvre they know it
this was the way in which France saved
civilization they they pioneered a new
concept of energy to take the place of
the Roman slave economy as far as farm
labor went as slaves become less
numerous farmworkers fall come
increasingly it to fall in the category
of serfs who are so minimally
distinguishable from slaves that it
seems like a difference in terminology
more than substance I'll talk about that
at a later time but Lefevre de nuit said
that it was the fall in the population
that led to this this big this big
technological change what was the
technological change and here I am so
happy someone asked that question
because it's one that fascinates me
and this has to do with the way you you
utilize animal power
that's a cow and if you are going to do
something with that cow to to make it
work you take advantage of the fact that
it's spinal process has some bones here
that are much larger than the others and
that stick up in a kind of a hub plus
the fact that the cow is really
interested in grass and so it keeps its
head down where the grass is so all you
have to do is put something up here you
can put it here or you can tie up to the
horns and tie it on here or tie it on
here
tie down wherever you want and and then
if you hook it to something back behind
let's say a plow if you can get the the
cow to move forward the plow will follow
it a little Digga a furrow in the ground
and this is where plowing came from but
in order to make it work it was felt you
had to have I mentioned before two of
these guys and the the the pole the beam
went across the necks of both animals in
a yoke and what you had here was not a
something like that but rather a beam
that went up between the two animals now
this was a was and remains an efficient
way to harness bovine animals all right
then you have
a horse now your horse doesn't have a
hump that's sticking up with all of this
this firm bony substructure so that if
you put a a bar on top of a horse and
then carry it over to the horse next to
him and you have something between them
something back here you want to pull and
they go forward it falls on the ground
because there's nothing to pull from so
in the Romans and the Greeks the ancient
Western world in general said you know
this is the only way we know of to
harness to animals and we have to have
to so how do we make it work for horses
what we do is we put on a strap here to
hold it in place but more importantly we
put on a strap here around the animal's
neck
what Lefevre could they know it argued
was if you do this and we have many many
many images from ancient Greece and Rome
showing precisely this way of harnessing
he said if you do it then the animal is
not pulling with its bony structure it's
pulling with its neck muscles and if he
pulls too much he strangles so horses
were not as strong as oxen to begin with
but if they had to have their their
labor determined by how tough their neck
muscles were because they didn't have a
bony structure on which to to rely in
pulling then horses would be rather
inefficient but for the Romans they
didn't care according to the temper they
know it because they had slaves and
therefore they were perfectly willing to
strangle their horses and use them for
pulling lightweight chariots or other
vehicles for the elite and not use them
for a lot of labour and so the French
came along and they invented what did
they invent according to the theft they
know it they invented the horse collar
where you had a collar horseshoe-shaped
collar that went around the neck and
instead of having two animals to have a
chain or strap on one side of a collar a
chain or strap on the other side of the
collar a connecting bar in the back and
then your plough was here what this
meant was that the force was transferred
from the neck to the animal's shoulders
not not from a hump but rather from the
from the shoulders behind the neck and
this invention of the horse collar was
conceived of as multiplying the energy
of animals and allowing society to
recover a tremendous amounts of Labor's
that have been lost with the demise of
the Roman slave population and the
general shrinkage of population in
Europe so
though was proved by later historians
that the French did not invent this it
nevertheless was a was and remains a
very important theory in the history of
Europe that is to say that you had a
fundamental change in the use of animals
for energy associated with new
harnessing techniques the dating of
those techniques is debated this is the
primary technique but there's one other
that I won't go into but we're now do
historians say the new techniques came
from they say they came from China so
you say oh well isn't that is that
convenient the Chinese were losing
population after the fall of the Han so
they must have had the same situation
and therefore if the French didn't
invent the horse collar it's reasonable
the Chinese did accept that the Chinese
invented it during the Han Dynasty
rather than after and its appears to
have nothing to do whatsoever with with
a abundance or a lack of a manpower
it seems to have more to do with the
ability of the Chinese to to adapt
technology without being captivated by
the notion of of animals operating in
pairs you find mixed animals you have
one in China going back to the Han
you'll have single animal harness double
animal harness triple animal harness I
ran across one with 23 animals and
harness so that's a bit later it if
anything if you know the the whole story
of harnessing focuses on the ideological
rather than the economic fixation of the
people in the West so that raised
question as to whether Roman slavery
really is that important when you look
at at the economy I've talked about in
terms of harnessing and the horse collar
there is another argument that I will
bring up in a few weeks having to do
with the rise of water power again
sometimes attributed to the to the need
for a different energy profile following
the the demise of the Roman slave
economy but the possibility that the
slave economy really wasn't that crucial
an element still is not investigated
very much so that when you have these
two silent entities to synchronized
States one in the West and one in the
East that both have strong economies at
least until they begin to to decline
that both have robust populations
how is slavery that is it that important
that slavery is used in one and not in
the other and I'm not sure it is but
it's a very important theme for the
history of slavery which is primarily a
theme in Western history now you do it
later Chinese history if you come down
to early modern period have a certain
amount of slavery but if you were
teaching a course in the world history
of slavery which could be a very
interesting course you really wouldn't
get that much out of ancient East Asia
and it you know it raises the question
as to what what is the real function of
slavery or the real meaning of slavery
within a society is it really an
economic form or is it a social and
political category that is better seen
in non-economic non-economic contexts
the now what happens after the Romans
and the Chinese
sort of play out their period of
imperial rule is again one of the things
that seems to warrant treating them
together because the Roman Empire is
succeeded particularly in its western
territories by a whole chaotic group of
principalities you know kingdoms duchies
etc associated with the settlement and
migration patterns of people speaking
Germanic languages this new population
element not only changes the demography
of Europe but it changes the the
political complexion as well and perhaps
even more profoundly it takes let's say
if the Roman Empire Falls and the is
it's declining days in the mid 400s and
it begins to Europe begins to get its
act back together around 800 when you
have Charlemagne becoming declaring
himself Emperor crowning himself Emperor
and realm then you have something like
four centuries of all kind of bad news
at least from the point of view of
anyone who wants to follow a linear
political narrative in China you get
about four centuries
Tom fall in the early 200s the Tong
reunify or rather this way the Tong just
as the Han followed a brief a
short-lived Empire done it for shim the
zwei were a short-lived reunifying state
that preceded the Tong so you have a lot
of four hundred years between
the end of the Han and the sway Tong
reunification of of northern China in in
Europe this is was for many generations
referred to as the Dark Ages a period
that either was not known or who cared
because it was no longer Rome Rome was
the big story and these petty states
came later were much less significance
until you begin to get some sort of a
glimmer of a restoration of Rome with
Charlemagne declaring himself an emperor
in China this is a period of a
substantial number of small states it's
sometimes called the Six Dynasties
period because there was a historian in
the Tong who wrote a book based on one
capital city in southern China what is
now the city of Nanjing in which there
was a succession of six ruling dynasty
so it becomes a sixth dynasty period
somebody else writes a history and says
there's a period of the three kingdoms
and looks at from another perspective
and sees a different sequence of things
but in any case you have a on both ends
the the end of the of the of the highly
organized state is followed by disunity
and competition among the various
claimants to power and a
the economic circumstances are such that
you as I said seem to have a substantial
decline in the population of the area
that have been under Roman Authority in
Europe and the area under Han Authority
in China and in both cases this lasts
this interval lasts about 400 years and
what is interesting in a sense when you
look at this whether you call it the
dark ages or you call it the six dynasty
period is that you have a dynamic new
religion spreading Christianity begins
of course in the first century CE II it
defines the first century CE II an old
terminology in the Roman Empire and
Buddhism begins to show up in China in
the first century CE II under the Han in
both cases it is the period after the
the decline of the state and indeed
after the demise final demise of the
state that has the largest expansion of
the new religion so that when Rome comes
to an end in the second half of the 400s
Christianity still is not really that
deeply implanted now I know that in with
Charlotte with Constantine in the early
300s you have Christianity made the
official religion of the Roman Empire
but that primarily applied to the east
the most heavily Christianized areas
were what we now would refer to as
Greece Turkey Syria Egypt and
Niva to some degree Iraq and I'm using
here Syria in the in the sort of macro
Syrian sense that beloved of the Assad
family in Syria to include what is now
Israel Lebanon and Jordan that's where
the Christians were and in Italy and
maybe in southern Gaul and some in Spain
but most of the Christians who later
become the heart of Christendom in the
West the Christians of Northern Europe
the British Isles Germany and heaven
knows Poland these people are are not
Christians at the time of the fall of
the Roman Empire so that it is the the
late empire that sees the spread of
Christianity and even more the post
Empire and the same thing in China
Buddhism is not a big deal for the Han
but under the six dynasties and the
three kingdoms Buddhism becomes a
powerful popular religious faith and the
the sway Tong period is marked by the
dominance of Buddhism so again this is
one of these tempting synchronicities is
there is there a meaning to this
now those people would argue for a
meeting would probably associate the
meaning with a personalization of the
notion of faith and salvation in other
words when you had a state that had
institutionalized religious forms that
relied upon the the role of the Emperor
or his minions acting on behalf of the
people for for formal rituals involving
the you know at least nominally
involving everyone then when that state
Falls and when the Emperor and his
minions are scattered in flight then
what is left of religion the Roman
temples and particularly those temples
dedicated to the two Roman emperors who
declared themselves to be gods of become
less and less appealing it would seem as
centers for religious faith with the
decline of the Empire and similarly to
have the Emperor sacrifice on behalf of
the entire people in the period of the
Han or to have his governors or other
officials conduct public sacrifices on
behalf of the people perhaps became less
and less appealing in the post Han
period with Buddhism as an alternative
now this is not to say that Christianity
and Buddhism were in any way you know
identical in the ways in which they they
appealed to people as
as personal ways of personally
expressing a faith
Christianity was salvation --all and
initially based on the notion that
Christians could you know work miracles
and heal people and things like that
Buddhism was based on the idea of
withdrawal and escape from the
inevitable pains of the world and go
through a sequence of reincarnation
until ultimate cessation of the cycle of
reincarnation was achieved whether you
call it a Nirvana or moksha or whatever
so they were different but they were
that they departed quite a bit from the
from the notion that the the ruler was
acting spiritually on behalf of the of
the people so maybe that there's an
important similarity there but it also
gets into the question of besides public
sacrifices and rituals carried out by
the ruler or carried out in temples that
are established by and recognized by the
Empire what was was there a
philosophical change and here you get
the final comparison that I'll mention
at this point and that is the degree to
which Rome and Han China were centers of
of
or places where philosophy and
government came together in a in a
fruitful and harmonious fashion on the
Roman side this this is primarily
related to stoicism with a a less
important from a governing point of view
philosophy of Epicureanism and on the
Chinese side
this was the spread of Confucianism
stoicism maintained that the
that doing one's duty particularly if
you were a state official and you have a
post that you were supposed to be
filling that that was a moral and
philosophical obligation even though it
in Ewa tably was going to make you feel
bad you you just sucked it up and you
did what you were supposed to do more
similar perhaps to some of the doctrines
that you have in India and the
bhagavad-gita with the notion of of
Dharma Venu would have in China but but
it was important philosophy it was a
philosophy that was espoused at the
level of emperors so that Marcus
Aurelius what are the better emperors is
a known stoic philosopher but also
trickled down to two lower levels of
population the Epicureans had a
different view of things they accepted
the stoic notion that you know life
really is pretty awful but they said the
the objective of life should not be to
to sort of cowboy up and get through
your duty but rather you should elect to
remain by the side of the road and not
take on the duties of state not take on
the duties of high office but to live
with as little emotional involvement and
commitment as you can because emotional
commitment is always going to turn sour
and hang out with some similarly epicene
friends and have dinner together and go
get drunk
just not involve yourself and then
eventually you will die and you won't be
reborn and it's know I'll get through it
was it was not a hedonistic philosophy
but it was a philosophy of removal from
society and the Chinese side you had
Confucianism Confucius as I say being a
thinker who lived in the 6th century
born in the 6th century BCE who had many
followers and who who expanded on his
doctrines and he was known for short
anecdotal statements or descriptions of
his behavior a form later on we'll find
of a prophet Muhammad that were taken as
as guides by his followers and those
again and again repeated the notion that
there are bombs of duty that the ruler
has to this to the subject the subject
has to the ruler the father has to the
wife of the wife has to them a husband
to the wife the wife to the husband the
father to the children the children to
the father the minister the older
brother to the younger brother at the
younger brother to the older brother and
the Minister of State to the Emperor and
the Emperor to the Ministry of State and
you were supposed to recognize these
forms of obligation and live by these
forms of obligation if you were going to
lead a proper life and one of the points
of obligation of course was to to serve
the emperor in the office to quit
you were appointed and this is very
similar to the stoic the stoic view and
indeed the Confucian doctrine raised the
issue of what does the minister do if
the emperor is a vicious tyrant and this
the Confucian answer was you remonstrate
you go to him and you say you sir are a
vicious tyrant I'll stop that and then
if he says no then you'll resign your
job but you do not revolt because you've
done your duty your duty is to
remonstrate to frankly say what you see
is wrong and if the emperor will not
accommodate it you now should leave or
should leave the stage and then the
assumption was that within the family
within the imperial family there are the
family members who would you know take
the emperor out back and cut his head
off and replace it with a better person
but you're you were bound by your duty
and your duty did not involve
overturning the state or rebelling or
anything of that sort and this is quite
stoic in his character now there is
another philosophy that competed with it
which was Taoism which was rather like
the philosophy of it of Epicurus it
called for people to withdraw from the
you know from the high traffic lanes of
the Imperial Highway and to stay by the
side of the road and lead peaceful and
uninvolved lives so you had two notions
of the relation of the individual to the
public or to the governing
style or the governing enterprise in
these two empires one of them was to
become involved and to faithfully
fulfill your duties the other one was to
withdraw and sit by the side of the road
and enjoy a long life like the
proverbial tortoise and against these in
each case you have a new religion coming
along that says something dramatically
different Christianity on the one end
and Buddhism on the other I know at this
university we have a retired professor
who teaches more than anyone else at the
university his name is Theodore Newberry
he was once the Provost of this
University he was a Provost when I came
here 35 years ago and he is one of the
paramount neo-confucian thinkers in the
world he's written a zillion books he
regards the core curriculum as sort of
something that he invented and he's
almost old enough to have done it he's
over 90 still taking about four courses
a semester and he is a kind of he kind
of exemplifies this Confucian outlook on
the world and it comes to mind because I
think his favorite saying of Confucius
of the Analects is in book two number
four I've heard him talk about this many
times is Confucius autobiography I mean
and he says the master said because
these were we repeated you know stories
told by his disciples the master said at
15 I had my mind bent on learning at 30
I had become established
at 40 I had no doubts or I was no longer
perplexed at 50 I knew what is ordained
by heaven at 60 my ear was an obedient
organ for the reception of truth at 70 I
could follow what my heart desired
without transgressing what was right and
barrios gives us as you know what the
proper Confucian life should be and I
cite it now because I'll be 70 in a
couple of weeks and I've been thinking
about this anyway that's all for today